invité ce soir de preuves par 3 jean
vincent placé secrétaire d'état chargé
de la réforme de l'état et de la
simplification bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous vous présidez également
l'union des écologistes démocrates des
démocrates et écologistes ont tous les
cas les écologistes qui soutiennent est
parfois participe au gouvernement des
stages en vincent placé pour répondre et
au cours de cette émission à trois
grandes questions d'abord après
l'horrible meurtre du couple de
policiers dans les yvelines comment
mieux se protéger le terrorisme
surveillez le terroriste était
surveillée on appris aujourd'hui par les
services de ce genre de renseignements
est resté également un ancien condamné
avait une liste de cibles potentielles
mais c'est aussi la république qui est
bien sûr attaque et deuxième question
comment sortons de la crise sociale au
soir de cette nouvelle mobilisation
contre la loi travail tendue à paris
d'ailleurs avec la présence une fois
encore de casseurs vous le dirai tout à
leurs amis kms de public sénat enfin
troisième question pourrait vous
empêcher une candidature écolo en 2017
une candidature autonome
lucile malandain qui a suivi ce week-end
le congrès d'europe écologie les verts
votre ancien parti vous interrogera sur
ce sujet mais bien sûr les froids à
nouveau après le double meurtre de ce
couple de policiers
un cap de l'horreur a été franchie
souligne manuel valls une minute de
silence tout à l'heure au sénat dans le
président gérard larcher est élue des
yvelines et il a évoqué bien sûr la
famille de magnanville et la famille
plus globale de tous les policiers ou
pensées vont également à leurs collègues
à leurs collègues de la police de ces
deux commissariats mais de la police
tout entière et plus généralement à nos
forces de sécurité
symbole de cette france qui ne doit pas
plier face à la terreur en votre nom à
tous je tiens à saluer à soutenir leur
action inlassable leurs actions
éprouvante leur action efficace sans
relâche au service de la population
quand on touche à un membre des forces
de l'ordre c'est la république qui est
atteinte c'est un double crime pour vous
aussi jean vincent placé comme l'a dit
le sénateur bruno retailleau contre une
famille et également contre la france je
crois que nous partageons tous
le même sentiment le même
ressenti par rapport à ce drame
épouvantable ce crime odieux et a été
dit très bien par le président larcher
par bruno retailleau par françois
zocchetto part bien sûr le premier
ministre est de mise intérieur remet pas
en politique sur de l'ensemble des bancs
politique c'est l'effroi et la
consternation donc évidemment une pensée
très émue pour les victimes pour ce
malheureux petit garçon entier lui bien
sûr à la chance d'être encore là mais
qui sera bouleversée baissé toute sa vie
et bien sûr l'ensemble des proches
chaudes et des familles est évidemment
salué des policiers les gendarmes qui se
retrouve avec ses collègues et cette
campagne qui était également d'ailleurs
membre de du corps dudit ministère de
l'intérieur donc ce sont d'abord les
victimes bien sûr c'est aussi là t'as
crête à la france avec cet individu qui
se revendiquait de l'état islamique a
alors germé non justement cet individu
qui en est fait vous l'avez indiqué
était suivi depuis plusieurs années oui
par nos services de renseignement et a
impliqué même condamné pour sa
participation à une filière de condamner
condamné bien sûr et qui ensuite à
exécuter d'ailleurs sa peine et qui se
retrouve là encore dans un pas
supplémentaire dans cette dans cette
folie barbare
alors je vous propose d'écouter les
précisions que le procureur françois
colas a apporté tout à l'heure au sujet
de ceux là aussi à bala le tueur a
indiqué être musulman pratiquant et
faire le ramadan il a précisé avoir
prêté allégeance trois semaines plus tôt
ou commandant des croyants de l'état
islamique
amir al baghdadi et il a ajouté avoir
répondu à un communiqué de cet émir qui
demandait je cite de tuer des mécréants
chez eux avec leur famille
alors comment mieux se protéger comment
réagir jal le gouvernement
oeuvre depuis le début du quinquennat
pas moins de trois lois anti terroristes
de loi sur les renseignements qui sont
d'ailleurs très exigeante très très très
dur qui ont trouvé un équilibre par
rapport à la nécessité de mener des
enquêtes et de lutter mais clairement et
bien sûr le respect de l'état de droit
et surtout des moyens la réalité les
ressorts honte et c'est apporter à dit
encore le 1er mai
oui on est aussi sans nulle sur
l'identité nationale il ya des critiques
oui le taux satisfaction joué par champ
pas au niveau du gouvernement de
polémiques vaines
le passé est le passé y compris sous le
quinquennat précédent
nous nous avons augmenté de près de 10
mille le nombre de policiers de
gendarmes qui avaient été supprimés des
renseignements généraux avait disparu il
a fallu réorganiser l'ensemble des
réactions du service de renseignement
intérieur et c'est ce qui a été fait il
y avait également eu des recrutements
près de 1500 dans le service de
renseignement intérieur
aujourd'hui ce qui est fait notamment
depuis les attentats par bernard
cazeneuve mise l'intérieur admirable et
je crois estimé sur tous les bancs aussi
bien au niveau du renseignement en
france au niveau du déploiement des
forces de police il ya également
l'opération sentinelle avec l'armée
qu'il faudra pas bien sûr et il faut
continuer à le faire davantage encore il
ya eu près de 100 personnes qui ont été
identifiées qui peut-être même était
susceptible de commettre ce type d'acte
et étudie des vidéos on le voit dans un
pays quand même très sécurisée parce que
l'on parle évidemment du drame français
mais nous pouvons aussi y associer ce
drame terrible à orlando
on va en parler aussi bien sûr mais
adjacent à la théorie trop fort ni
homophobe des profils comme celui de
l'art aussi à bala il y en a peut-être
des centaines aujourd'hui en france
alors la question se pose qu'est ce que
l'on fait aujourd'hui on est est ce
qu'il ya des mesures de précautions qui
s'imposent
il ne faut pas que nous rentrions dans
un état d'anxiété absolue notamment les
françaises et français parce qu'il faut
continuer à vivre il faut continuer à
les travailler moncontour mieux protéger
les français nés les policiers on s'y
fier le travail qui est fait dans le
cadre aujourd'hui de ta d'urgence pour
cet essai
qui voulait polémiquer par rapport aux
mesures prises par le gouvernement et y
compris le maintien de l'état d'urgence
j'espère que y compris dans les semaines
et dans les mois qui viennent y voit la
réalité de la situation permanente en
réalité dans laquelle nous nous sommes
dans cette guerre absolue contre l'état
islamique et convoi qui sont présents et
très clairement présente alors qu'elle
soit d'ailleurs des attentats organisés
ou alors que ce soient des individus
comme cela je ne finirai par les dreal
et de réprimer psychologie d'individus
mais d'évidence il est toutefois dans
cette folie barbare est tout à la fois
dans cette revendication de façon froide
même parce que pouvoir assumer cette
revendication en téléphonant aux numéros
d'urgence avec quelques moments avance
et c'est quand même une à milan ac
froide et hier soir c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les yvelines avec notamment
des messages postés sur twitter par par
le tueur un émail des scènes également
qu'il a filmée en direct des voix
s'élèvent à droite pour réclamer que ces
individus qui sont repérés donc un
soient placés dans des centres de
rétention qu'en pensez vous faux je
pense même que celles et ceux qui
portent ce type de proposition savent
que ce n'est pas possible
et j'en suis même sûr que s'il était au
gouvernement ils ne feraient pas sur
quelle base juridique
sur quelle base juridique eh bien on
peut mettre des gens ainsi dans les
centres de rétention
s'il ya une base juridique de toute
façon il ya une écoute il y a peut-être
un mail il ya eu une interception d'une
quelconque communication et de toute
façon cela sont appréhendés parce qu'il
ya un fait générateur
sur quelle base on mettrait des
individus quel individu en rétention
administrative
cela me paraît extrêmement éloigné de ce
qu' il s' emilie possible de faire en
terme de droit et ne s'est en effet
attaché à l'état hongrois notre
démocratie et je pense même d'ailleurs
que il faut essayer d'éviter de faire ce
type d'effets d'annoncé parce que les
mesures qui sont là ont vocation à être
déployé davantage
et d'ailleurs il ya aussi un travail au
niveau européen à faire enfin on a
progressé sur le pnr notamment pour
pouvoir suivre les uns et les autres le
fassent aériens majeurs ayant un code
qui permet de suivre à la trace les
individus au sein de mg et là on est
face à ce que par exemple la sénatrice
que vous connaissez bien nathalie goulet
nomme les djihadistes de proximité c'est
à dire oui on ceux qui sont sensibles à
ce discours de haine il n'y aura aucune
sur internet et le premier ministre a
dit très clairement de façon extrêmement
lucide il n'y a pas de risque zéro il
n'yad'ailleurs de risque zéro dans
aucune activité et donc qu'il l'a il
faut assumer je vous dis renforcer
encore les moyens intensifiée et
d'ailleurs qu'il me soit permis aussi de
saluer le travail formidable des forces
de police et de gendarmerie qui sont
déployés pour lutter contre le
terrorisme qui sont déployés aussi dans
la protection de l'euro 2016 de tous les
grands événements puis aussi surtout au
quotidien tous des blancs 16 et tous les
français
on écoute tout à l'heure le premier
ministre au sénat et il évoquait une
menace globale nous faisons face à une
menace globale sont face à un ennemi
extérieur que nous combattons en irak en
syrie en syrie la france y est
pleinement engagée et l'état islamique
recul mais nous savons qu'il a encore
des capacités de frappe et vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous même rappelé partout
d'ailleurs dans le monde
et puis nous combattons cet ennemi
intérieur sur notre sol c'est les mots
que d'ailleurs j'avais moi même prononcé
ici au sénat à l'automne 2012
c'est une guerre c'est un combat de très
longue haleine qui évidemment ce couvent
en profondeur la société française
face à cette menace globale il faut
faire preuve de beaucoup de
détermination de beaucoup de sang-froid
voilà un ennemi intérieur donc une c'est
une guerre dit manuel valls mais pour
marine le pen cette le crime de trop
elle estime que la lutte implacable
contre l'islam il doit enfin commencer
donc pour elle ça n'a pas véritablement
commencé dans notre pays que répondez
vous le dépouillement des moyens je
viens de vous le dire est tout à fait
significatif est tout à fait remarquable
nous sommes dans les difficultés
que nous avons pu rencontrer sur les
questions budgétaires nous avons déjà
assumé le sérieux budgétaire qui porte
ses fruits nous parlerons j'imagine du
retour de la croissance
et dans cette situation nous nous avons
fait des choix politiques sont très très
clairs en matière de protection des
biens et des personnes
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
je voudrais pas rappeler non plus dans
le quinquennat précédent qu'elle a été
par exemple la courbe de décroissance du
nombre de nos militaires et cette
réalité et compris présent république à
assumer en revenant en sur le plan
budgétaire sur ce qui a été prévu en
termes également de sérieux budgétaire
en matière militaire
eh bien on voit que sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets la police gendarmerie
militaire
renseignements initiatives au niveau
national fermeture et contrôle des
frontières le fait que nous ayons été
extrêmement volontariste au niveau
européen
le fait que nous sommes dans la
coalition de lutter contre l'état
islamique dahesh en syrie en irak il ya
les choses sont claires j'ai je crois
d'ailleurs que ça me saluer au niveau
mondial et respectée au niveau européen
pour notre détermination on a compris
dans quelle maison dallage franchement
sur l'action du gouvernement ne va pas
de donner de leçons de quoi que ce soit
et qu'elle essaye d'entretenir les peurs
les haines en cherchant à diviser et
celle en réalité qui est quelque part la
philosophie la stratégie de neige qui
consiste justement et c'est diviser
notre pays alors que dans des périodes
comme aussi difficile que celle ci comme
de suite au drame notamment d'hier
l'unité de rassemblement sont vraiment
les éléments essentiels pour la cohésion
nationale
alors vous l'avez rappelé jean vincent
placé cette attaque en france est
survenu deux jours après la tuerie dans
la boîte gay orlando aux états unis
donald trump a aussitôt attaqué un
barack obama pour ne pas bien nommé le
danger l'islam radical on écoute le
milliardaire candidat donc à
l'investiture républicaine aux états
unis
les terroristes de l'islam radical
après une boîte de nuit pour cible qui
non seulement parce qu'il voulait tuer
des américains mais aussi pour tuer des
citoyens gay à cause de leur orientation
sexuelle
c'est une attaque contre ce qui me
définit en tant que nation
quand je serai élue je suspendrai
l'immigration en provenance de régions
du monde ayant un passé avérée de
terrorisme contre les états unis
l'europe ou nos alliés jusqu'à ce que
l'on comprenne pleinement comment mettre
fin à ces menaces des thés à l'instant
barack obama dénonce la rhétorique de
donald trump sur les musulmans mais jean
vincent placé est ce que c'est si
difficile de nommer l'islam radical
ce que refuse à faire jusqu'à présent le
président américain et les choses sont
très claires il faut il est évident
qu'il est hors de question de mettre en
exergue les musulmans l'islam d'ailleurs
catherine tasca danse la question
qu'elle a posé tout à l'heure au premier
ministre à une formule très précises en
indiquant que c'étaient des terroristes
qui prenait prouvant qu'ils étaient dans
un djihad d'un islam qui cherchait à
dévoyer et cette formule est très
précise et veut dire très bien ce
qu'elle veut dire c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes évidemment en
amitié en fraternité avec 99,9 pour cent
des six millions de musulmans de france
qui sont chez eux ici en france qui
participe à la cohésion nationale qui
participe à notre économie qui
participent à ces aliments social sa
protection écologique qui sont des
citoyens français ou étrangers
d'ailleurs et qui vivent sur notre
territoire s'agit pas de les stigmatiser
il s'agit de dire les choses très
clairement et qu'il y à des djihadistes
kid qui dévoient un islam ultra radical
qui est totalement inacceptable et qu'il
nous faut combattre mais ce n'est pas
l'islam que nous allons combattre ces
nous allons combattre le terrorisme
nous allons combattre les djihadistes et
on veut viens de parler de madame le pen
on voit bien que la même rhétorique et
chez donald trump et on comprend bien de
thé ce qu'il ya derrière comme idéologie
je les dis de fractures d'opposition de
renvoyer des uns vis-à-vis des autres
monsieur 30 lui il est même quasiment
dans la haine des hispaniques qui font
aussi les états unis qui sont nombreux
qui apporte énormément de richesses et
de culture aux états unis d'amérique et
on voit bien aujourd'hui que face
ou difficulté globale du monde
occidental qui est bien moins dominant
qu'il ya peut-être une trentaine
quarantaine d'années il faut expliquer
aujourd'hui que nous sommes dans une
compétition internationale et que dans
cette compétition internationale il faut
développer notre économie font nos
muscles et il faut nous fortifier il
faut se diversifier faut trouver des
partenaires des alliés et c'est plutôt
comme cela et y compris en et en
accueillant que nous réussirons à
développer notre pays est sûrement pas
d'un repli identitaire pour nous
proposons alors en france le débat sur
l'insécurité est aussi alimentée par les
violences commises par les hooligans
venu pour l'euro vous êtes un passionné
de foot et les jeunes souligne on a
assisté à des combats inouïe à marseille
et côté la sénatrice socialiste samia
ghali qui n'est pas rassuré du tout pour
le prochain match à risque au vélodrome
au stade vélodrome à marseille elle
était toute à l'heure en direct sur
public sénat qui inquiète le plus les
marseillais c'est hulk règne pologne où
là on risque d'avoir encore
malheureusement des affrontements avec
des pays qui ont besoin de s'affronter à
ne pas qu elle seule sait pas que sur le
terrain malheureusement et qui risquent
de s'affronter encore sur l'espace
marseillais dont comment je demande tout
simplement ce qu'on garantisse la
sécurité des marseillais
parce que vous avez parlé de supporters
pour moi ce sont pas des supporters ce
sont tout simplement des individus qui
viennent se battre dans des pays qui ne
sont pas les leurs alors face à ces
violences la polémique là encore sur les
failles du dispositif de sécurité est
peut-être plus sûrement vous allez
pouvoir réagir à sur la légèreté sinon
la duplicité de certains pays on a parlé
de la russie qui a laissé passer tout le
monde pourrait ne sait exactement ça
c'est à dire que le miz intérieur
bernard cazenave est intervenu tout à
l'heure il ya il y avait mille policiers
sur place est-ce qu'on se rend compte de
ce que ça veut dire pour protéger un
match de football que justement dans la
situation que nous vivons sur la
question de la sécurité des françaises
et français qu'on mobilise déjà mis deux
personnes c'est tout simplement énorme
et ça démontre aussi qu'il n'y a pas de
risque zéro quand il ya des brutes
avinées qui n'ont d'ailleurs rien à voir
que le football seront sur des gens qui
voient la paix qui boit plus que de
raison avant le match qu'il voit à peine
le match et qui ensuite vont continuer
leur soirée destructrice après donc ils
n'ont rien à voir ce que certains des
hooligans
est-ce que l'euro pourrait être une fête
mais bien sûr bien sûr et pour 98
si vous souvenez ce bosseur il ya déjà
eu ce type d'exactions malheureusement
je vais pas d'ailleurs les banalise
mais malheureusement il y en a à peu
près à chaque match qu'on avait que des
confrontations outils pour le coup
effectivement samia ghali connaît très
très bien le football aussi parce que j
wallon va pas stigmatiser des pays on va
stigmatiser en revanche quelques
spécialistes si j'ose dire de ce type de
débordements et c'est vrai que bon je
vais être peut-être un peu très bien
mais russie angleterre pour le coup
quand on connaît le hooliganisme et qui
a dans ces deux pays et puis leur
relation avec l'alcool non pas les pays
mais léo ligue 1 eh bien on se retrouve
avec un phénomène accru et quand il ya
comme ça des centaines de personnes qui
sont dosés guérilla urbaine parce que
c'est ça cette réalité-là intervenir
avec des policiers qui soit extrêmement
courageux je répète qu'il ne soit encore
permis de saluer leurs actions vous
aurez le gain est encore de le pour le
coup pas de chance parce que je parlais
tout à l'heure justement avec samia
ghali judy mais tu as tu n'as pas citer
le match à risque et elle me dit en
effet eu crime pologne âgé dire
effectivement là c'est pas de charge que
après il ya le la france elle manie je
crois qui a lieu à marseille aussi
je suis sûr ça va bien se passer et il
faut faire en sorte que ça soit d'accord
une fête est d'ailleurs aussi noter que
sur les fans zone ça se passe très bien
monsieur aulas n'est pas la petite fête
la 2e' keita mais il apparaît que ça
s'est très très bien fait passer aussi
vraiment ça démontre aussi et il ya eu
tout à l'heure aussi une question moi
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour m de
madame cayeux mais qui justement faisais
une espèce de parallèles entre euro 2016
disant on ne s'est pas comme ça qu'on va
gagner les jo 2024 c'est sûr qu'une
image du bas bones dont garde ont raison
et soutenons notre pays et montrons nous
savons organiser dans des conditions
bien difficile parce que quand même dans
une situation difficile soutenons aussi
notre tourisme national
juste avant la période estivale et
arrêtons et des news est la france vers
des images aux parlementaires vont
dire dans l'hémicycle du sénat devant le
premier ministre avec tout ça comment
peut-on faire pour gagner les jo-2020 4
je peux vous dire que partout on ne
regarde et à los angeles à rome et on
arrive et on dit des conneries tu auras
si on ne regardait regarder les mêmes
les français pensent que dans faisons
nos regards de pays voyons voyons nos
forces et nos faiblesses
on est là pour nommer les choses c'est
ce que vous allez continuer à faire dans
cette émission n'a pas masqué la réalité
avec cette deuxième partie où il sera
encore question de violence car les
casseurs sont à nouveau passé à l'action
à paris en fin d'après midi la nouvelle
manifestation du jour donc contre la
halle au travail alors comment sortir de
ces crises sociales vous allez dire à
michael szames s dans un instant d'abord
on écoute ce phoebe nec et le numéro
deux de la cgt et qui était tout à
l'heure en direct du cortège sur public
sénat donc c'était tout à l'heure à
paris je crois que le gouvernement doit
retrouver la raison et doit comprendre
que ce mouvement est majoritaire que les
salariés sont déterminés que les jeunes
sont déterminés qu'on ne lâchera pas et
donc il faut réécrire ce projet de loi
qui n'a pas été négociée qui n'a pas été
débattue qui n'a pas été voté à
l'assemblée nationale et que personne
n'en veut aujourd'hui en france ça fait
des mois qu'on appelle au dialogue après
il faut que les conditions du dialogue
soit au rendez vous c'est à dire que la
ministre accepte enfin de discuter du
contenu de son projet de loi est donc
discuter des points qui posent problème
aujourd'hui la version la hiérarchie des
normes l'augmentation du temps de
travail et les baisses de salaires la
facilitation des licenciements la casse
de la médecine du travail etc etc
c'est de ça dont il faut parler vendredi
à l'ats vendredi donc la réunion entre
philippe martinez de la cgt et myriam el
khomri enfin ils vont se retrouver ils
vont se parler et il y a eu cinquante
huit interpellations aujourd'hui à paris
michaël szames s 29 s'en méfier blessés
et onze manifestants un mickaël vos
questions tant qu'agent message aura sur
place et sort le premier ministre a dit
qu'il y avait une haine anti-flic c'est
votre avis y dément je trouve que c'est
tout à fait incroyable que alors que
notre pays dans cette situation alors
que on a connu ce drame terrible et et
bien il y ait encore des gens qui je ne
confonds pas les manifestants et les
casseurs bien sûr mais qu'il y ait
encore des gens qui puissent cinq
régions
dans des manifestations qui sont
évidemment pacifique pour aller
dans des magasins détruire des
devantures l'hôpital necker mais enfin
un escroc se rencontrent de quoi il
s'agit mais le fait que dénoncer demande
aussi comment est ce qu'il est possible
que ces gens viennent dans les
manifestations pour casser ça fait des
semaines que saleh ont malheureusement
c'est pareil c'est assez fréquent c'est
assez difficile parce qu'il suffirait
qu'il y ait une intervention plus
musclée plus sévère de la police et que
évidemment dans cette espèce de deux des
espaces étroits où il ya tout à la fois
de manifestants sympathique et pacifique
et le casseur on se retrouve vite le
verrou qui n'existe oui c'est la même
manière là on ne peut pas il faut la
police ference au maximum et laisser
d'intervenir avec d'ailleurs respect des
manifestants et du droit de manifester
il croyait ces casseurs là il faut
intervenir très rapidement les isoler et
c'est extrêmement difficile à réaliser
bien sûr ça a assez duré évidemment que
c'est assez duré et d'ailleurs je le dis
moi je ne confonds pas ni les
manifestations ni les grèves avaient
aussi ce qui s'est passé sur le blocage
des raffineries des stations service des
ports ça c'est inacceptable c'est
inacceptable et la cgt et commencent
d'ailleurs à le comprendre
y compris le retour autour de la table
de monsieur martinez la table de
discussion ce il nous dise madame qui
est numéro deux de la cgt dire enfin on
en a discuté et
c'est ça fait six mois qu'on leur dit
qu'on est prêt à discuter il ya eu le
rapport
combrexelle qui dit un an un an c'est la
personne n'a voulu j'aurais entre le 49e
n'a voulu discuter mais le passage
parlementaires qu'ils soient des
fanatiques du 49 avenue ruel est
d'ailleurs le droit d'utiliser 49,3
était fortement réduit
ce n'est même pas nous c'est la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 de nicolas
sarkozy entend mieux une deuxième fois
selon vous si ça continue comme ça oui
parce que c'est ça fait un an que nous
sommes dans le processus le rapport
combrexelle
après on en pense ce qu'on veut de ce
rapport mais il ya une volonté de
discuter de myriam el khomri la cgt de
fo
personne n'a voulu discuter ensuite
l'avant projet de loi on en pense qu'on
veut aussi moi pour ma part j'étais
plutôt quand même favorable à la version
initiale donc je prends les alès parents
il ya croyons nous sommes aujourd'hui
nous avons eu une discussion et que
syndicats réformistes qui ont vous qui
sont bientôt la table qui ont discuté
c'est quand même un sort de la classe et
était d'une salle mais j'essaie de
refaire le parcours mais quand même
parce que le fait de dire non on n'a pas
discuté dans ses fonds nike aurait
énormément discuté à l'assemblée
nationale il ya eu des jours et des
jours deux commissions cinq mille
amendements 500 amendements qui ont été
pris et à un moment bon il faut
s'arrêter
c'est à dire que pour le gouvernement le
corps est essentielle du texte c'est
aussi l'article 2 est le président le
premier ministre avec l'autorisation du
conseil des ministres ont décidé de
s'engager responsabilités vous entendez
ce qu'il ya dans la rue quand même vous
n'avez pas élu pour ça c'est une forme
de trahison politique
non je ne pense pas je pense que nous
avons été élus notamment pour préserver
notre modèle social
le modèle social français il est juste
extraordinaire il est extraordinaire de
la halte garderie jusqu'à divertissement
sont jusqu'où nos grandes de france
hôpitaux je vous propose que je voudrais
qu'il y à l'étranger bien sûr c'est
qu'un hôpital à l'étranger on travaille
on avait justement et pour protéger ce
modèle social nous avons besoin d'une
économie compétitive
nous l'avons assumer et compris moi par
exemple sur le crédit d'impôt
j'avais l'occasion de dire qu'on pouvait
trouver d'autres moyens d'aider
directement les entreprises ont tout
pour susciter des débats le code du
travail
il faut l'assouplir il faut le rendre
plus flexible et il faut apporter
davantage de sécurité aux salariés et
donc c'est cet équilibre là qui a été
trouvé par exemple en effet en
privilégiant les accords d'entreprise
pour être plus souple et flexible et en
faisant le cpa loconte personnes
activité de la même manière moi j'ai
reçu parce que je reçois tout le monde
mais j'espère qu'on en parlera dans mes
sujets de réforme de l'état simplifie
les entreprises oui d'accord mais j'ai
reçu des artisans j'ai reçu les petites
entreprises
allez vous dire que sur la pénibilité
sont plus que critique tort car abondant
oui nous assumons que nous n'avons pas
pu satisfaire toutes les demandes du
patronat
c'est de la cgt incontestablement non
plus et cette ligne là qui est équilibré
d'une forme assumer que je dis comme
cela dans ma section de sécurité
les choses sont claires alors moi sur la
notion de trahison sinon de revirements
ecoutez-le attaque à la tribune du sénat
du secrétaire national du pcf c'est
pierre laurent qui s'est exprimé
récemment sur le sujet
qu'il me soit permis moi de vous relire
la motion majoritaire adopté au congrès
du parti socialiste de juin 2015 juin
2015 c'est pas en 2008 dont manuel valls
et de nombreux ministres sont
signataires
je lis la démocratie sociale que nous
devons construire d'assad doit s'appuyer
sur un syndicalisme fort et respecté
constructif sur l'innovation
intransigeant sur les régressions
sociales
et puis je continue la citation il faut
rétablir la hiérarchie des normes
la loi est plus forte que l'accord
collectif est lui-même s'impose au
contrat de travail
si la loi peut permettre à des accords
de déroger à ces dispositions
elle ne peut le prévoir dans des
domaines relevant de l'ordre public
social salaires minimums durée légale du
travail droit du licenciement existence
de la représentation du personnel
force est de constater que à peine six
mois plus tard votre projet de loi
prévoit en matière de dyarchie des
normes et de régression sociale
exactement l inverse
edit trahison
les parisiens la ligne de la motion
n'avait pas signé cette motion
il s'adressait au gouvernement hier de
gouvernement je note que le secrétaire
général du parti communiste français et
pour lequel j'ai le plus grand des
respects le parti communiste français
son secrétaire-général lit attentivement
les motions du congrès socialiste et sa
propre intérêt puisqu'il s'agit des
contradictions voulu répondre je lui
dirai simplement que je respecte
beaucoup ses positions qui sont tout à
fait légitimes et je lui dirais aussi
qu'il serait plus utile au lieu d'avoir
choisi un peu qu'on en parlera j'imagine
après aussi comme les verts le repli
identitaire commune aux communistes
eh bien ils feraient mieux de venir
raconter tout ça aux réunions que nous
faisons de la belle alliance populaire
avait invité dans la confiance dans
l'alliance que nous avons créé avec jean
christophe cambadélis et puis avec
sylvia pinel du parti radical de gauche
avec mes amis du déo avec des françois
de rugy également eh bien il serait
beaucoup plus utile et à la gauche et au
pays en discutant avec nos y compris de
façon taquine comme il le fait plutôt
que de rester dans un splendide
isolement
parce que c'est ça au fond le vrai sujet
tous les débats sont justes et légitimes
après qu'est ce qu'on veut est-ce qu'on
veut peser dans des majorités
ou alors est-ce qu'on veut tenir des
discours d'ailleurs qui sont
intéressants et bien et bien dit mais ça
na ça n'a pas beaucoup de sens quand on
a la chance dans un quinquennat comme
celui ci d'avoir un président de gauche
oui et une majorité de gauche il suffit
de voir ce qui est en train de faire le
sénat et la droite par rapport au texte
je voudrais que même là vous faites
venir laurent comprennent bien que c'est
pas lui se diriger ce pays bas se voit
mal un président communiste pour la
france et bien c'est les options et je
le dis aussi je respecte aussi jean luc
mélenchon mais je pense que ce sont des
gens qui sont durablement minoritaires y
compris par rapport à leur vision du
mouvement sur la droite et je dis juste
que la haye roger simple le choix le
simple qu'on le veuille qu'on le veuille
pas le choix il est sur la politique
portée par le gouvernement ou alors ce
que fait la droite
ou alors ce que c'est et quand je vois
en clair c'est un jeu très claires ce
qui se passe au sénat bien sûr c'est la
remise en cause des 35 heures
c'est aussi le fait pour le coup qu'il y
ait un ultralibéralisme en réalité
aujourd'hui le projet de droite
ils doublent sur la droite thatcher et
reagan des années 80 non mais il y
aurait en fait j'ai jaugé pour l'état
lorsque l'on dit on va enlever deux cent
cinquante mille fonctionnaires moins
cher et j'ai fait tous ceux qui
participent aux manifestations avec la
cgt à bien comprendre ce que ça veut
dire
deux cent cinquante mille fonctionnaires
au moins dans notre pays sur un
quinquennat mesures proposées par celui
qui paraît-il les centristes qui
monsieur juppé alors écoutons le coup
rapporteur du texte
il s'appelle jean baptiste lemoyne donc
sénateurs les républicains et il
s'adresse le aussi au gouvernement comme
le précédent intervenants là vous avez
la réforme honteuse ou vous récusez le
fait de contourner de tenter de
contourner les 35 heures eh bien nous
nous avons la réforme revendiqué il faut
dire les choses
vous ne les dit pas et vous cherchez on
l'a vu à travers votre discours qui est
un peu une reprise du meeting que vous
avez tenus la semaine dernière
finalement essayé de vous refaire une
santé sur le dos de la majorité
sénatoriale
je trouve que c'est pas de très bonnes
pratiques ici la tradition effectivement
d'avoir un travail approfondi article
par article et vous nous verrez les
équilibres que nous avons trouvés ont
leur propre qu eric aisément s'ils
gagnent en 2017 est ce qu'ils arriveront
à appliquer leurs réformes
moi je n'avais pas dans une situation où
je fais des mélodies aujourd'hui moi je
souhaite que nous des vols par
exactement aux pronostics les sea shanty
mais je souhaite surtout que nous
défendions notre bilan que nous fassions
campagne moi je suis partisan que le
président de la république serait de
nouveau candidat qui soit donc candidat
à sa succession et tuez nous ayons un
projet encore plus vaste d'ailleurs ici
on parle un moment de réformes de l'état
de sa punition
moi je fais déjà beaucoup de choses
depuis quatre mois j'ai attention d'en
faire aussi beaucoup pendant dix mois
parce que je pense que et c'est
d'ailleurs une des fierté que j'ai
d'appartenir à ce gouvernement parce que
on aurait pu se dire ah non des
élections oulalalala attention ça va
servir
vous avez une grande rue victime le choc
de simplification c'est difficile parce
qu'il ya des mauvaises habitudes qui
sont prises les administrations une
petite tendance à pas forcément
simplifier et clarifier ou en lisibles
les documents et moi j'essaie de faire
en sorte que
notre état soit plus agile plus
dynamique plus convivial plus de
proximité et c'est un boulot permanent
parce que il ya une vraie valorisation à
faire de ce qui se fait aujourd'hui dans
les préfectures ce qui se fait dans les
maisons de services au public en termes
d'accueil dans la ruralité et il y a
aujourd'hui une administration qui se
réforme nous n'ont pas choisi comme
justement la droite de stigmatiser y
compris avec ce qui a été fait la
révision générale des politiques
publiques jeune femme avec un
fonctionnaire est en place aujourd'hui
nous nous le faisons avec la
modernisation de l'action publique
nous regardons secteur par secteur les
contraintes qui sont celles de la vie de
l'état et de la puissance publique
nous avons fait des choix clairs pour
lisser gendarmerie justice éducation jaj
est bien ailleurs ayant faire des choix
et ailleurs on a su de regarder ce qu'on
appelle techniquement la revue des
missions et l'évaluation des politiques
publiques et on essaye de faire nos
qu'il peut y avoir des mieux avec moins
mais bien sûr mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire comme approche de dire nous c'est
250 mille ans - puis c'est comme ça
c'est une approche ultra secteur ultra
idéologique mais je vais vous donner
même un exemple dans d'autres non non
mais ça c'est vous dire ça c'est
intéressant parce que depuis je suis là
on dit mais parce que il y aura une
réforme qui va s'appeler réforme placé
parce qu'il ya une loi
moi je suis sympa de les saisir je sais
pas de faire
ce qu'il faut pour que ça tombe bien
pour votre émission certes j'ai un truc
à par exemple non mais exactement sur la
réforme de l'état ce sont de très
nombreuses mesures on a fait 70
valuation de politiques publiques ça
peut concerner tout à la fois la
navigation de plaisance ça va peut-être
vous faire sourire
l'économie sociale ou solidaire où
l'écologie mais je pourrais vous donner
plein d'exemples de la façon dont on
améliore la vie quotidienne et un seul
très simple c'est que aujourd'hui il va
y avoir un déploiement de la révolution
numérique
il arrive d'ailleurs peut-être un peu
tardivement mais nous allons avoir avec
france connect la possibilité que dans
un parcours numérisés extrêmement
efficace et lisible et claire et
ergonomique
eh bien nous allons avoir chaque
français qui avec un identifiant qui
soit celui ve d'amélie 11 oui ou un de
l'impôt ont fait choisir à son
identifiant de départ et ensuite il
pourra surfer dans tout le parcours de
l'administration car ce n'est pas encore
totalement développées mais vous vous
direz j'habite je sais pas à montpellier
déjà c'est très développée à montpellier
une ville très numérisés et vous verrez
toutes vos procédures qui pourront se
faire ainsi que celles des opérateurs
prendre des rendez-vous à la caf
on va vous faciliter la vie de la
relation avec l'administration et ça
c'est possible parce qu'il ya des
stratèges dont notamment dans
l'administration j'ai l'honneur de
diriger le secrétariat général pour la
modernisation de l'action publique et
que par ailleurs il y à des
fonctionnaires qui se forcent ainsi
évolué saviez-vous qui change
oui exactement c'est à dire volontariste
pas à pas et des choses concrètes parce
que et c'est pour que ça je suis content
de répondre à monsieur grossir c'est que
c'est toujours à mais est-ce qu'il faut
qu' il y est votre wii moi je peux vous
dire oui et je ferai un bilan est
d'ailleurs on fera déjà un bilan d'étape
avec le président la république mi
septembre parce que nous allons
continuer les mesures de simplification
notamment en matière d'économie verte
une éolienne en france franchement 70
pour sortir une éolienne
moi je veux qu'on puisse la faire en
trois ans c'est simple parce que reçoit
vaguement niveau que les européens
l'économie sociale et solidaire
les start-up les entreprises du
numérique les toutes petites entreprises
voilà il ya énormément de choses à faire
et moi je vais vous dire je passe ma vie
en fait un peu d'ailleurs ça vous faire
peut-être sourire à le faire un peu
voiture balai de tout le monde parce que
ceux qui vont par exemple au mistral
économie ou d'écologie
pour x ou y raison mes collègues font
très bien leur boulot mais ils sont
insatisfaits ils débarquent chez moi à
la fin en se disant tiens lui puisqu'il
fait la réforme de l'état simplification
toute la force et on se dit mais qu'est
ce que ça veut dire et tout à la fois ça
peut peut-être nous avancer nos affaires
et bien moi je fais ça chaque voiture
balai tous les syndicats de patrons de
2,2 du président gattaz à monsieur
asselin et se creuser monsieur marc
enfin tous ceux qui sont à même de
commerce j'ai reçus tous les syndicats
sauf d'ailleurs la cgt mais j'espère que
à prévenir ma vie j'aurai l'occasion de
voir monsieur martinez tous les
syndicats professionnels et c'est
passionnant de voir comment on peut pas
à pas finement réformer le pays
très bien alors merci mais troisième
partie plus politique maintenant à de
preuves par 3 pourrait vous empêcher une
candidature écologiste autonome en 2017
vous allez le dire hallucine malandain
de l' agence france-presse
et il ya des candidats potentiels mais
l'écologie politique se porte mal au
plus mal comme l'expliquent le
politologue roland cayrol parti
écologiste sous ses différents noms il a
toujours été en crise c'est c'est un
parti dans lequel il ya des sensibilités
des mini faction des courants des
ambitions qui n'ont jamais arrêté de se
heurter
mais au moins on était arrivé à avoir un
modus vivendi et il a fallu que ce soit
au contraire l'arrivée au gouvernement
kick ass ce modus vivendi on peut dire
que jean vincent passé placé est l'un
des acteurs essentiels de cette fracture
il est de ceux qui ont pris le risque
la responsabilité de dire non on reste
plus dans ce parti vert qui devient un
parti un peu trop sectaire d'extrême
gauche ou purement écolo moi je fais de
la politique
moi je pense que la politique c'est
important et la politique ça se fait
dans les alliances et du coup il a
préféré les alliances en l'occurrence
avec les socialistes et les radicaux de
gauche plutôt que le maintien au sein du
parti voilà roland cayrol interrogé par
jean belloc évoque donc vos
responsabilités passées à europe
ecologie les verts bonsoir lessive mont
saint michel bonsoir jean vincent placé
pour soi
alors qu'en pensez vous comme roland
carole l'écologie politique
il connaît très très bien le sujet je
puis quelques pas je pourrais même dire
c'est flatteur pour pour moi est quelque
part aussi moi je suis un peu triste de
ce qui se passe parce que comme l'a dit
roland cayrol mon action pendant 15 ans
à direction de ce parti moi j'étais la
direction de ceux de ce parti et j'ai
essayé de rendre l'écologie politique
responsable d'une grande maturité
pragmatique réaliste efficace et c'est
comme cela d'ailleurs que nous avons
réussi et j'assume parce que la
politique c'est aussi avoir des élus
participer à des élections les gagner ce
qui est quand même mieux que de les
perdre exercé des responsabilités dans
les mairies dans les régions j'étais
vice président aux transports à la
région ile de france c'est un mandat et
que vraiment j'ai eu et j'ai exercé avec
passion camp écologiste pouvoir faire
avancer aller plus vite d'ailleurs pour
faire des bus des tramways des métros
des rer c juste captivant et puis c'est
comme ça qu'on lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
et c'est sûrement pas en étant
uniquement dans l'opposition au même
dans les associations dans les ong que
je respecte totalement mais ce n'est pas
la même fonction
back est quelque part aujourd'hui ce qui
se passe c'est à dire c'est chez vous
ces débats samedi au congrès vous avez
vu le repli
le repli identitaire et la chute pas de
prob avec les personnes moi j'ai
beaucoup de vous le connaissez
l'habitant oui très bien si ça a été mon
collaborateur donc je connais très bien
ensuite il a été mon bras droit au sein
du parti et nous
je suis pas me mêler des sujets d un
repli identitaire avions parlé de
running stratégique est là depuis 18
mois depuis la sortie du gouvernement
donc il ya une divergence très forte
avec david comment avec cécile duflot et
puis sont ni les petits tas de la
majorité de ceux qui est resté et ce
n'est pas là le sujet ce n'est pas une
conséquence à la rupture avec le ps
le le vrai sujet c'est la ligne 2 je
suis tout seul à 2% et j'ai raison et
donc vous allez gens nous la question de
quelle est l'utilité de se positionner
pour les convaincre à travailler moins
ce qu'ils veulent maintenant j'ai
d'ailleurs fait que cécile duflot se
prépare oui mais très sain la répéter
pareille pas de problème de personne
au contraire moi j'avais j'aime plutôt
et david carbon et cécile duflot à titre
personnel mais d'évidence quelle serait
l'utilité d'une telle de candidature
elle elle accuse presque nommément
françois hollande
en tout cas le gouvernement la majorité
et serra d'assassinats politiques un peu
désagréable il faut pas confondre le
suicide et d'assassinats
il faut assumer sa part de
responsabilité ça fait deux ans que ils
sont sortis du gouvernement au moment où
nous allions engager la france non non
mais ils sont vous étiez encore aux
membres de l
mais moi j'ai protesté surtout dans la
perspective de la coop 21 tant qu'on est
écologiste qu'on a la chance de pouvoir
accueillir le moment majeur de la vie
d'écologie sur la planète
après des échecs que nous avons
dénoncées qui nous ont fait de la peine
depuis copenhague 2009 jusqu'à lima 2014
que nous avons la chance d'accueillir la
coupe 21
vous savez pour le monde entier moi
partout je voyage parce que j'ai la
chance aussi d'être le responsable
français pour le partenariat pour un
gouvernement ouvert qui est une autre
façon d'envisager la démocratie
notamment par rapport au numérique et sa
complète évidemment et même quelque part
c'est la base même de ce que je fais au
niveau de la réforme de l'état et de la
simplification
quand on a la chance d'avoir ce
partenariat et à chaque fois je me
déplace donc on nous saluons la réussite
exceptionnelle de de françois hollande
est le fait même que justement on agisse
parce qu'à un moment il y avait des
polémiques sur le budget des connus
d'accord mais l'écologie c'est global
quand par exemple grâce justement à
notre action la caisse des dépôts et
consignations que chalut s'élancer
totalement alors que vraiment c'était
parce qu'il faisait d'habitude dans la
transformation écologique de la
transformation énergétique dont je vois
des crédits qui sont mis par la caisse
des dépôts sur ces investissements
totalement innovant aujourd'hui donc
vous êtes cette grange bilan écologique
du quinquennat j'ai bien sûr j'aurais
préféré plus je vais même vous dire
j'aurais préféré que ça commence plutôt
parce qu il aura fallu assez bizarrement
attendre peut-être et que justement il y
ait cette sortie du gouvernement
cueillie surtout la coop 21 pour que
notamment signé plus d'écologie mais je
vais vous dire je trouve que ségolène
royal a été plutôt efficace et nous la
chance que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est
que ségolène royal elle se bat sont au
sujet sur glisse ofag il faut at elle se
bat sur les perturbateurs endocriniens
le combat qu'elle mène à commission
européenne est saluée y compris parfois
sur l'huile de palme et des produits
bien connu du l'huile de palme ça n'a
pas été facile tellement son
volontarisme et et là enfin on est
aujourd'hui d un pays qui démontre dans
le monde une forme d'excellence
environnementale capable de 106 à écolo
en 2001 candidat écolo qui pourrait
gagner un candidat y aurait un candidat
écolo qui pourrait gagner et son
présidentielle comme par exemple le vert
autrichien mais le candidat autrichien
par an non non non le candidat
autrichien il est ou alors nous sommes
sur sa ligne politique où il est sur
notre politique une écologie
entrepreneuriale ils n'ont que régis qui
intègre le réel une écologie qui
s'appuie sur l'économie verte notamment
pour faire progresser d'écologie
souhaitiez que françois hollande soit
candidat bien aujourd'hui mais que c'est
le meilleur candidat pour l'écologie
s'il y avait un candidat et que le gist
pur sucre le président de la république
est socialiste et je pense social
démocrate mais c'est à lui de se
qualifier s'il y avait un candidat
écologiste qui soient en situation de
pouvoir gagner ça pourrait s'évaluer
mais d'évidence il n'existe pas et donc
à partir de ce moment là dans le champ
de la gauche le meilleur candidat c'est
toujours qu'on le veuille qu'on ne va
pas le président la république appuyée
sur ce bilan de la com 21 et de l'action
de ségolène royal
et donc je peux vous dire que je suis
alors extrêmement à l'aise non pas dans
des baskets moi je n'ai pas de basket
mais les dents des chaussures pour
assumer bien sûr le soutien clair à
celui qui a réussi à cap21 et à la
politique du gouvernement dont celles de
ses gonds rial qui me soit permis aussi
de saluer mes collègues barbara pompili
et maya lauqué dans leur secteur
vous avez évoqué cécile duflot vous dit
elle s'est suicidée en fait et la clusaz
france hollande de meurtres politiques
vous l'avez dit alors il ya un autre
candidat qui hésite lui alors que cécile
duflot se prépare c'est nicolas hulot
écouter ce que dit à son sujet françois
de rugy votre complice je trouve qu'il
fait preuve de lucidité et d'une
certaine sagesse c'est à dire qu'il dit
je réfléchis mais justement il dit je
réfléchis à comment pas lui nicolas
hulot mais comment les idées écologistes
les projets écolo peut peser dans les
années qui viennent et certains le pouce
il le dit à être candidat moi je pense
que ce serait une mauvaise idée je l' ai
déjà dit parce que s'il était candidat
d'abord je pense que il ne prendrait
beaucoup de coups qui ne mérite pas mais
en plus ils finiraient sans doute dans
un une impasse qui est celle de la
division parce que la division de la
gauche et des écologistes
elle mène à l'élimination alors moi je
préfère éviter l'auto élimination elle
nicolas hulot cette mauvaise idée bref
c'est pour ça aussi on s'entend bien que
françois de rugy d'une intense que
j'étais pro non pas un mot à ajouter ou
à retrancher de ce qu'il vient de dire
oui en faveur très sincèrement j'ai
conservé que j'ai constaté que et les
verts le soutiennent en espérant qu'il
n'y aille pas pour pouvoir recommencer
leurs divisions pour désigner un
candidat à un bras ce qu'ils ont quand
même réussi à 3000 personnes à voter en
france à avoir cinq motions ce qui est
quand même juste incroyable mes amis
communistes uec un peu l'impression que
pour ceux qui disent hulot c'est pour
éviter
mélenchon et mélenchon lui ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que hulot le soutiennent
donc j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui soutiennent faussement à
françois on aimerait bien aussi que
nicolas hulot le soutiennent al assil
pas je pense que ce serait le plus
cohérent parce que s'il ya quelqu'un
aussi qui a oeuvré plein réussie de la
coop 21 sous l'autorité du président de
la république
c'est nicolas hulot était évidemment une
arme extraordinaire enfin je suis plutôt
dire et en pacifiste et un joker
extraordinaire dans la réussite de la
cap 21 et ce qu'il a fait eh bien il a
oui le poids avoir vocation à le faire
dans un deuxième quinquennat et je crois
soit d'origine pour le coup était très
clair ça je ne vois pas moi je vous dis
très clairement entre mélenchon qui est
une offre politique incontestable sur le
fond qui n'est pas la nôtre qui les deux
vers 9h alors je suis fini ma phrase
donc jean luc mélenchon et françois
hollande il ya eu il ya une grille des
gosses différentes c'est
incontestablement très diverses mais
j'ai l'impression quand même très
sincèrement que même si vous y accorder
beaucoup d'audience aux uns et aux
autres
entre le pc et les frondeurs en réalité
dans l'opinion dans l'opinion
entre jean luc mélenchon et françois
hollande il n'y a rien derrière y a
personne à part ça d'accord je lis que
mélenchon a fait une conversion s'est
converti au logis très très clairement
qu est ce que vous pensez de cette
allocation écologique moi c'est
d'ailleurs son écologie ressemble
beaucoup à celle des verts actuellement
c'est à dire que c'était il y avait chez
les verts plusieurs courants y compris
moi même j'ai animé le courant real au
pragmatique entrepreneuriale et j'assume
et
aujourd'hui
jean luc mélenchon incontestablement et
moi je crois j'ai pas de raison de ne
pas croire à sa sincérité
bon avant il était plutôt ultra jacobins
je crois qu'il est toujours un peu
contraignant que régional mais bon il
est il était plutôt pro-nucléaire
il était plutôt productiviste il a
évolué et je le dis moi je préfère les
converti à l'écologie que ceux qui ne
parlent pas du tout d'écologie donc il
est convertie etc il le fait bien avec
le talent qu'on lui connaît tant sur le
plan culturel rhétorique la qualités
oratoires après qu'on a dit ça en fait
c'est écologique il incarne c'est ce
terme d'heures qu'il n'utilise plus sur
la planification écologique c'est-à-dire
une vision quasiment marxiste de
l'écologie qui est d'ailleurs un peu
celle des verts en réalité les verts
aujourd'hui je suis pas sûr qu'ils ne
finiront pas avec mélenchon tellement
ils sont devenus d'extrême gauche mais
pour en revenir à jean luc mélenchon
nous avec lui d eux que j'ai l'honneur
de présider union des démocrates
écologistes avec jean luc bennahmias et
qu'on se dirige avec d'autres nous nous
voulons avoir une écologie n'ont pas
seulement réaliste et pragmatique mais
je le répète entrepreneuriale avec moi
je pense que pas un seul instant que ce
sont les normes les contraintes c'est
pour ça que je sais la simplification
mais pas seulement vont aider la
protection de l'environnement une classe
juste une phrase je pense qu'aujourd'hui
avec le monde l'économie qui se
développe ainsi et notamment l'économie
verte est une chance extraordinaire tout
à la fois pour la planète et pour
l'emploi c'est en aidant les grandes
boîtes à la conversion écologique à la
conversion même si c'est au départ je
vais dire des noms total veolia
l'élu point de départ edf lorsque edf se
lancera totalement et dans l'énergie
renouvelable et bien ça fera non pas
seulement les petites éoliennes convoi
par ci par là et c'est cette
transformation la à laquelle je veux le
vrai et je pense que franchement je
serais bien plus utile à la planète que
justement ceux qui sont là il faut
regarder avec des jumelles en se
rapprochant de l'ex majordome d'un mot
sur et des effets sur ségolène royal
vous l'avez rendu hommage et vous
soutenez sa décision de d'approuver la
prolongation de la de vie des centrales
donné les graves de 10 ans et nice vous
pouvez me répondre oui ou non mais c'est
impossible nous avons besoin de votre
question est tronqué répondent à une
saison tranquille et prolonger la
décentralisation
transition énergétique des des choses
très clair qu'on va aller vers 50% de
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité on est à 74 %
toute la droite a dit 'nous on reviendra
sur la houle sur la loi donc pareil pour
les écologistes c'est la droite qui veut
revenir sur la loi où nous et nous nous
devons alors pour oeuvrer parce que vous
avez la lumière vous allez me parler
parce que en plus il fait très chaud il
ya énormément de lui même
vous avez la lumière c'est parce que y'a
d'électricité donc moi je ne suis pas
pour le retour à la lampe à pétrole
alors serait bien ennuyé mais on parle
évolution alors mais je vous dis juste
une chose très simple et bien pour faire
en sorte que ça continue sur une
mutation de 10 ans oui il faut prolonger
d'accord voilà votre réponse est oui
alors non je finis ma phrase monsieur
gossio et en même temps il faut enfermer
ses centrales te dire qu'on prolonge de
dix ans quelques-unes un peu comme les
voitures par exemple vous savez et je
finis pour sortir du diesel déjà il ya
le combat politique on va finir par
sortir du diesel parce que déjà avant
c'était 80 % achètent des bâtons et déjà
soit écouter écouter quand vincent placé
non peut pas le faire parce que par
exemple vous si vous avez acheté deux
voitures diesel hier eh ben je veux pas
vous demander de la vente demain ça n'a
aucun sens c'est à peu près mais comment
est-ce que vous devrez passer du rôle de
procureur implacable du quinquennat
c'était au début on vous l'avait dit
d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
c'est assez saisissant quand vous êtes
venu nous voir ya quelques années
aujourd'hui en avocat enthousiaste
écoutez les commentaires de quelques
sénateurs écologistes qui se sont
exprimés sur vous à notre micro
peut-être qu'il trouvait que le
gouvernement ne faisait pas des choses
assez bien lorsqu'il n'y était pas
maintenant il doit être formidable
ce que je sais c'est que véritablement y
travaillent donc ce qu on veut nos
ministres qui travaillent que est plutôt
dans le bon sens si c'est vrai qu'on
entend plus du tout il est dans les
petits papiers de monsieur hollande il a
eu un poste de secrétaire
bon je trouve que c'est quand même une
très belle récompense donc il doit quand
même se taire on a pas on n'a pas les
choses sans rien il faut enfin voila il
il pense aux prochaines élections je
suppose c'est vrai une phrase je les
regrette pas beaucoup vous ne regrettez
pas ce sont tous des anciens auditeurs
vous avez entendu de diversité de propos
et très sincèrement ce qui d'ailleurs on
arrive à fait pas non mais je vous
explique en plus je les aime bien tous
les mets juste une fois je les aime bien
tous les trois mais ce qui tue
l'écologie c'est la critique permanente
voilà parce que ils savent que les et
présidé quatre ans est bien content que
les présidents laquelle vous ne
souscrivez plus on l'a compris ce soir
au nord de moi je vais vous dire gg
j'ai la chance de pouvoir faire des
choses pour la france et c'est ce que
j'ai toujours voulu faire et je l'assumé
merci merci merci à tous bon soir et a
très vite